ja ich habe mich heute aufgeregt über
rot heißt ich war nämlich am bahnhof und
habe wollte ein ja wir wollen ja alle
lange leben ein wasser und das shirt
kaufen ich sage unsere fahrt knapp
sieben euro ich habe so ist der salat
auch dabei er kommt extra dick sein geld
verdient sie wenigstens mehr dann dachte
der mann da da kannst du nichts anfangen
so ist das nicht und wir merken es ja
alles jeden tag alles wird zu zeit
teurer nicht nur öl und gas an alle
lebensmittel dinge des täglichen lebens
wenn überhaupt etwas da ist die
begründung für diese stark steigenden
preise könnte auch das ist der reine
krieg der krieg in der ukraine
dann sind die lieferketten die wieder
auseinander brechen dann ist es die neue
pannen in shanghai und was weiß ich die
begründung ist klar aber die wahrheit
ist ja das sind gründe die na ja die
auch zum teil vorgeschoben sind denn
warum ist alles bei uns in deutschland
so viel teurer als im europäischen
ausland
war ist viele machen sich nebenbei die
taschen voll viele nutzen sie die lage
um ihre preise nach oben zu schrauben
und die gewinne einzustreichen und damit
wir nicht alle dauernd braucht sein muss
finanzminister davon bin ich überzeugt
jetzt eine wirklich bahnbrechende
maßnahmen umsetzen muss die
mehrwertsteuer senken auf zehn prozent
und den reduzierten beitrag auf fünf
prozent und das dauerhaft bürokratische
monster wie sie jetzt gerade beschlossen
sind der eine kriegt 300 euro mehr muss
davon aber die hälfte oder ein drittel
dann wieder ansteuern abzahlen oder es
gibt einen zuschuss aber nur wenn man
einen monat lang wohngeld bezogen hat
die helfen wirklich gar keinem weiter in
dieser situation und lindt da muss mehr
sein als ein minister der als nächstes
großes ziel wieder nur die schwarze null
erreichen will der muss seine
finanzpolitik dazu nutzen
wirtschaftspolitik zu entfesseln
unternehmen möglich zu machen starts
möglich zu machen und den menschen
dauerhaft das zurückgeben was ihnen aus
der tasche gezogen also mehr freiheit
schaffen mehr freiheit wagen durch mehr
wirtschaftspolitische freiheit denn so
kann er lindner sich und die fdp als
tolle marktliberale ergänzung zu der
staats dirigistischen haltung von robert
habeck dem wirtschaftsminister wirken
und darauf ein werk und so kann er auch
wieder wahlen gewinnen und davon haben
dann alle was
drinnen bürger
sollten fdp berater werden
das klingt recht namen im konzept und es
ist ja in der tat auch so ein bisschen
konzept das ist auch schon mal bei der
cdu gab da gab es ja schon mal den
professor aus heidelberg wien gerhard
schröder immer genannt hatte hat ein
bisschen selben schiffstour wo der
damals gesagt hat 25 prozent steuern für
alle dann ist das auch ganz einfach und
alle zahlen gleich und so ein bisschen
kommt mir das jetzt mit dieser herr
abgesenkten mehrwertsteuer
ehrlicherweise auch vor es führt ja doch
nämlich dazu dass du nur ungleich dass
man eine ungleichheit hat bei dem die
leute betroffen sind also du zahlst du
dann auch nur zehn prozent auf die rolex
uhr wenn du dir eine kaufst aber man
zahlt eben zehn prozent auf die
produkte des täglichen bedarfs im sinne
von kleidung auf lebensmittel fällt ja
sowieso der geringere satz an aber weil
es was ich wenn man sich eine blaue hose
oder ein paar schuhe kauft dann zahlt
man eben auch nur zehn prozent und das
sind auch die leute die weniger geld
haben in einer anderen weise betroffen
als die die sowieso viel geld haben und
deswegen bin ich immer dagegen dass man
das so über einen kamm schert muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen sondern ich bin bei
dir ist es bürokratisch fürchterlich was
da passiert gerade
man könnte das wahrscheinlich auch ein
bisschen intelligenter machen aber es
ist auf alle fälle im ergebnis gerechter
weil es eine stärkere umverteilung
zwischen unten und oben oder oben und
unten ist und deswegen werde ich nicht
dafür dass wir machen ich sage ja auch
dass das ein erster großartiger impuls
ist weil wir haben gesehen bei der
letzten temporären kurzfristig
mehrwertsteuersenkung gab es ja auch
viele gesagt haben das wird alles
aufgefressen
es gibt sogar berechnungen von leuten
gesagt haben 60 prozent ist nur
umgesetzt worden aber es gibt jetzt
keine neue studien von der universität
von notre dame aus usa hoch angesehen
die gesagt haben 35 millionen wurden
zusätzlich in den wirtschaftskreislauf
gesteckt weil die menschen nämlich
anschaffung vorgezogen die paar cent
maschine das auto oder was auch immer
dann werden sie eben nicht vorher werden
sie eben nicht zusätzlich in den
wirtschaftskreislauf gesteckt sondern
sie werden eben doch es gibt durchaus
team hinter werden daraufhin müssen
games kaufimpulse also wenn die
närrische neues feld wird ist es
tatsächlich so dass es kaufimpulse gibt
ich wäre allerdings trotzdem auch bei
einer der differenzierten modell ich
kämpfe zum beispiel im
familienpolitischen raum schon lange
darum dass zum beispiel gerade
kinderartikel babynahrung und sowie der
mehrwertsteuer runter wir leben ja in
einem land wo sie auf hundefutter nur 7
prozent mehrwertsteuer bezahlen aber an
babynahrung 19 prozent und das sind so
dinge wo ich sage also im täglichen
bedarf die lebensmittel das wo gerade
auch familien die die sich nicht mehr
weiter einschränken können weil wir
haben sehr viele ganz normale
durchschnittsfamilien die wissen nicht
mehr wo sie sparen können die werden von
den energiepreisen und von den ganz
normalen lebensmittelpreisen und so
weiter aufgefressen also all das was man
braucht um kinder groß zu ziehen und was
man zum täglichen bedarf wenn wir dort
einen mehrwertsteuersatz komplett machen
bin ich absoluter drei aber wie sehr ihr
natürlich dass das dass das kernproblem
sie sagen die gruppe der der eltern wird
benachteiligt für die müssen wir mehr
tun brigitte zypries sagte die rolex
träger sollen nicht ist kann hier
übrigens ist hier übrigens sollen nicht
gestützt werden sondern es sollen die
sozial benachteiligten sind jeder
fordert eine eine kleine klientel gruppe
und keiner denkt ans kranz deswegen bin
ich dafür einen radikalen schritt zu
machen und das impuls zu nehmen unser
steuersystem wirklich zu vereinfachen
und zu sagen wie kriegen wir lieben
besten impulse für die wirtschaft gegen
diesen staatsdirigismus der parallel
läuft christian du die möglichkeit hat
sein geld jeden monat rüber zu schieben
zu wollen ch beck der das gut aber
trotzdem verteilt starts dirigistisch
wir brauchen hier mehr freiheit das ist
das doch